[Música]
colombia conocerá este martes el informe
de la comisión de la verdad después de
cuatro años de investigación un equipo
de france 24 estuvo en el magdalena
medio de conducción de primera mano las
historias de las víctimas
y la y maxwell será sentenciada en
manhattan eeuu ella ya fue condenada por
ayudar a su entonces pareja jeffrey
epstein a abusar de niñas con guardias
de la prisión donde está temen que ella
se suicide como lo hizo el
multimillonario
día internacional del orgullo lgtb de
pumas a propósito de la conmemoración
este martes hablaremos de las peleas
legales que tiene la comunidad trans en
venezuela para que los documentos
reconozcan su cambio de nombre y de
género
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
mi nombre es málek la calle y estos son
los hechos más destacados de américa
comenzamos en colombia este martes la
comisión de la verdad publicará el
informe en el que ha trabajado durante
cuatro años para conocer más de lo que
ocurrió durante la guerra en ese país la
comisión es una entidad creada por los
acuerdos de paz de 2016 con la entonces
guerrilla de las farc alba santana y
lionel buseghín estuvieron en el
magdalena medio colombiano y hablaron
con varias de las víctimas
en este pueblo bañado por el río
magdalena una de cada seis personas ha
sido víctima del conflicto armado como
el exsindicalista ciro quiroz que lleva
toda una vida de lucha cuando era más
joven a peleo por los derechos de los
trabajadores y ahora lo hace por la
memoria de un 'falso positivo'
este joven
también víctima recibió amenazas
paramilitares cuando trabajó como líder
sindicalista en una empresa de aceite de
palma a los 90 por él pero sobre todo
por los que murieron exige verdad el
concepto de la verdad
es algo sanador algo que brinda una
satisfacción a la vida y como muchos
otros en gamarra tiene esperanzas en las
conclusiones del informe final de la
comisión de la verdad o la cero como
elevada
cómo estás como esa mesa de víctima de
gamarra creada a partir de los acuerdos
de paz del 2016 en la comisión lleva
seis años recogiendo testimonios de
víctimas y victimarios
con unos objetivos muy claros brindar
verdad justicia reparación y no
repetición a los colombianos en el
magdalena medio la presencia de
guerrillas como lln o las farc ep y
sobre todo de grupos paramilitares ha
hecho que el trabajo aquí sea todo un
viaje
por él
por el dolor por la vida sin un viaje
por los hombres
abrieron su corazón para contarnos más
arriba en el cauce fluvial en este
pueblo pescador el río es sinónimo de
vida pero también ha visto mucha sangre
luz escapó por poco de una matanza
paramilitar en un restaurante a ella la
violencia le dejó un trauma
porque por sobre todas las cosas pues
siempre a dar amor tratado de de echar
adelante cerca del río en
barrancabermeja no todos han dejado
atrás la violencia
alfonso se autodenomina firmante del
acuerdo de paz pero tiene que llevar un
chaleco antibalas siempre que está en la
ciudad el que una vez fue comandante de
las farc ep es ahora objetivo militar de
las disidencias por luchar por la paz
para nosotros significa algo muy
importante
significa una garantía de la
implementación del acuerdo de paz porque
como dice la conocida sin verdad no hay
futuro una de las consignas que vertebra
la comisión de la verdad que espera
poder dar respuestas a las víctimas
y pasamos a eeuu este martes se conocerá
la sentencia de gala y maxwell quien fue
condenada en diciembre por ayudar a su
entonces pareja jeffrey epstein abusar
de niñas la cárcel de brooklyn donde
está recluido a maxwell la puso bajo
vigilancia pues temen que se suiciden
como lo hizo a sting de alcohol chen nos
cuenta más
guilén maxwell hija del magnate
británico de medios de comunicación
robert maxwell y condenada en diciembre
por tráfico sexual será sentenciada este
martes en la corte federal de manhattan
podría pasar el resto de su vida en la
cárcel este fin de semana la sentenciada
denunció amenazas a su seguridad por
parte del personal del centro de
detención los guardias sospechan que
ella quiere atentar contra su propia
vida les preocupaba que tal vez
estuviera buscando meterse en una celda
individual para poder hacerse daño a sí
misma así que la pusieron en una
vigilancia de suicidio
de fixing su difunta pareja se suicidó
en 2019 mientras esperaba su juicio ella
le ayudaba a buscar niñas y participaba
en los abusos
fue condenada por tráfico sexual
conspiración y transporte de una menor
con intención de participar en una
actividad sexual ilegal lunar monsieur
es de manera unánime el jurado declaró a
william maxwell culpable de los peores
crímenes imaginables facilitar y
participar en el abuso sexual de niños
crímenes que cometió con su socio de
muchos años y conspirador jeffrey
epstein
el gobierno pide al menos 30 años de
prisión sus abogados denuncian una
ascendencia injusta y argumentan que el
gobierno dirigió su atención sobre ella
sólo después del suicidio de eps y para
aliviar a las víctimas y reparar la
reputación del departamento de justicia
sin embargo los fiscales señalan su
falta de remordimiento y la acusan de
ser una depredadora sofisticada que
sabía exactamente lo que hacía se prevé
que maxwell apele la sentencia
con la derogación del fallo roe versus
wade por parte de la corte suprema de
eeuu varios jueces de los estados más
conservadores están bloqueando
temporalmente la nueva norma y toman
posturas a favor del aborto a pesar de
que allí se están activando leyes para
el acceso a la interrupción voluntaria
del embarazo
en los estados más conservadores avanzan
las prohibiciones al aborto tras la
revocación de la sentencia roe versus
wade pero algunos tribunales buscan la
manera de garantizar este derecho a las
mujeres estadounidenses en luisiana uno
de los tres estados de eeuu que
aprobaron leyes de activación para
restringir severamente el acceso al
aborto un juez impidió temporalmente su
entrada en vigor
significa que los abortos pueden al
menos por ahora- reanudarse en luisiana
hasta la audiencia del 8 de julio eso es
por supuesto siempre que en ningún
tribunal superior ningún estado ningún
tribunal estatal de apelaciones o la
corte suprema de luisiana intervengan en
el caso y levanten la suspensión
en utah un magistrado otorgó una orden
de restricción que bloquea la ley de
activación durante 14 días considerando
una solicitud de planned parenthood
defensores del derecho al aborto de
arizona ohio wisconsin también están
intentando apelar la prohibición y en
california los legisladores acordaron
someter a votación una enmienda
constitucional
la asamblea permitiría a los votantes
aumentar la constitución de california
para prohibir que les lo niegue o
interfiera con la libertad reproductiva
de un individuo en sus decisiones más
íntimas y permitiría a nuestros votantes
dejar claro que en california al aborto
y la anticoncepción no son cuidados de
la salud y son un asunto privado entre
un paciente y sus proveedores médicos el
lunes 22 fiscales generales emitieron
una declaratoria conjunta a favor del
aborto y en defensa de este derecho
este 28 de junio es el día internacional
del orgullo lgbt
más la fecha conmemora las luchas por la
igualdad como la que se busca en
venezuela- la comunidad trans denuncia
que el poder electoral y el servicio de
identificación no permiten realizar el
trámite para cambiar el nombre y el
género de sus documentos
igual
quintero es una activista de derechos
humanos de la comunidad transgénero en
venezuela que ha luchado durante 20 años
por la igualdad de género y la no
discriminación hoy ha visitado al
parlamento como otras tantas veces para
exigir al poder electoral y el servicio
de identificación del país poder cambiar
de nombre y de género el anteproyecto de
ley que permitiría expresamente el
trámite permanece guardado en la
asamblea nacional desde hace más de una
década lo digo con todo el peso que
tiene esto es falta de voluntad política
a diferencia del resto de américa latina
venezuela junto a paraguay son los
países con mayor atraso en cuanto al
cambio de género en la identidad para
las personas trans la persona va a
buscar el trabajo de la entrevistan y ya
casi cuando la va a contratar que piden
los documentos
ángel pérez tiene 34 años es técnico
superior en enfermería haber cambiado su
aspecto físico de mujer a hombre le ha
costado varios puestos de trabajo desde
hace dos años está desempleado tuvo
clínicas de alta gama donde tú puedes
presentar la prueba escrita laboral
todas las ecológicas eco técnicas pero
cuando en tu expresión de género y ven
que tú tienes una expresión masculina y
un título femenino puede estar el cargo
y pueda ver la emergencia no va a entrar
ángel presta servicio comunitario de
enfermería en este módulo de atención
primaria manejado por el gobierno él
también ha sufrido discriminación
incluso de parte de funcionarios
públicos vestirse como hombre lo ha
llevado a ser detenido por supuesta
usurpación de identidad ya no para
margarita me detuvieron porque yo iba a
traficar droga porque esa cédula no
correspondía con lo que yo veía en el
caso de venezuela la mayoría de personas
trans están limitadas a unos pocos
oficios rumí logró abrirse paso como
instructora de danza pero se considera
una excepción recientemente el
ministerio público anunció la creación
de una fiscalía especializada para
atender a las personas de la comunidad y
diversa una pequeña batalla ganada en la
lucha contra la no discriminación que
adelanta esta comunidad
hasta aquí las noticias sigan en france
[Música]